hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga and today I'd like to step
back into the world of demon slayer
because this series sent an earthquake
into the anime world as well as the
manga world with volume sales surging to
absolutely ridiculous numbers following
the very very successful anime so in
what seems like an instantaneous motion
demon slayer has reached the pinnacle of
storytelling at least temporarily and
there are a lot of factors that
contributes to this such as likable
character as a decent story and of
course as mentioned before a stellar
anime adaptation however these to me are
more minor factors in what has built
demon slayer whereas i believe the key
to its success is in a much more simple
concept that has been woven into the
entire fabric of the series the concept
consists of one word and that word is
family now just to be clear this is
definitely nowhere near a new idea I
mean most shown in series do have some
focus on family be it blood relatives or
earned comrades however none of them
explore this idea like demon slayer does
because in this series finding a new
idea in regards to family is about as
common as oxygen and as a result it
makes the storytelling of Demon Slayer
hit incredibly hard during key moments
before we go any further if you have not
read the manga then never fear because I
won't be detailing spoilers here I mean
the anime series is more than enough to
adequately convey the point of this
video but I actually think that family
is a heavily underrated narrative
feature I feel like a lot of series try
to distance themselves from family as
much as possible because of the
potential complications that they
foresee it creating because you know the
problem is when a main character has
family that can weigh them down and make
them unable to embark on some grand
adventure because they have a
responsibility to their loved ones take
a series like one piece for example the
most successful manga of all time each
of the main protagonists have a family
in some form although most of them are
dead but as a result they are allowed to
go out into the world to pursue their
dreams whilst in regards to living
family when applicable
well Luffy in 22 years of publication
has never even met his father so that
should give you a good indication of
that and no it's not that simple and
families used a great effect but it is
not the core idea of a series like one
piece but if we say move into the board
of Salem briefly then we do have an
example of a series where family is the
core idea which would be Full Metal
Alchemist the heart and soul of that
series has the brotherly bond between
Edward and Alphonse and the power of
that bond is powerful
throughout the run of the series leading
to incredible emotional highs and lows
it shows the incredible potential of
this broad idea and demon slayer takes
that and amplifies it to a global scale
and the most obvious parallel here is
the relationship between Tantra and
Nezzer Co which actually mimics the
Edward Alphonse relationship quite
closely with them being siblings on a
mission to restore the body of Nezzer Co
but this is the obvious one and I'm not
going to spend too much time on it as a
result but already just be aware that
family is the driving force of the
series from a protagonistic standpoint
however in a rather uncharacteristic
move especially for Shonen it is also
the core idea from the standpoint of the
antagonists in fact the introduction of
the series antagonist whose donkey-booty
suji didn't occur in the aftermath of
some giant battle or in a deep dark lair
plotting like many shown in series but
instead he was introduced to randomly on
the street with his family and that was
a great shock to the system of both
tandro and the audience you know the
whole how could this guy who slaughtered
my entire family be a decent-enough
existence to have a family of his own
and of course whether or not kyboot cg
actually cares for his family is almost
irrelevant it's more that this was how
he was introduced to tandra and the rest
of us as the antithesis of what we would
have thought he was prior to this moment
that is the simple power of adding the
idea of family into the mix even a
superficial one but with kyboot cg the
idea of family runs much much deeper
because the series goes to great lengths
to continuously state that all demons
are related to him and not only that but
some are closer relations than others
depending on if he sides him directly
and how much of his own blood was
provided to any particular demonic
individual so when a really twisted way
family is also what is driving the
antagonistic forces of the world as well
especially at the high levels filled
with demons constantly striving to own
kyboot suji's approval as if he were an
actual father figure but family also
comes out in the individual motives of
demons as well with probably the
greatest example of course being rui
whose character development took place
around the concept that he was searching
for his true parents because his human
parents attempted to murder him after
rui became a demon despite of course
loving him dearly and so he went about
crafting his own demonic family
essentially enslaving a whole host of
demons to act not only as his parents
but as his siblings and of course as
soon as rui sees the bond between tantra
and new Zucco he realizes that what he
has is absolutely nothing and goes on to
seek family in another
mana by assuming that taking a Zuko will
imprint that bond on to him by default
and now with all of that in mind what do
we think rui ends up being defeated by
yes you guessed it family despite being
more powerful than tandra Onizuka Rui is
overcome at least temporarily by their
familial bond however it wasn't just
Andrew anneza ko it was the whole
Commodore family unit you know in his
moment of need tonzura sought help from
their father and know Zuko was
encouraged by their mother resulting in
an absolutely impossible moment that
gave tandro the opening he needed and
this portion of the series is still
probably my favorite moment to date
which is also likely heavily influenced
by the spectacular anime adaptation of
it but it shows the power of family and
the incredible payoff that this idea can
have when implemented correctly but it
also isn't just an idea that's explored
within the main protagonists and
antagonists like I said earlier the idea
family is quite literally everywhere in
Demon Slayer and to demonstrate this we
can go all the way back to the early
phase of the series featuring Yoko ducky
and in this case his family bones were
with the orphaned children that he had
trained and rather sadly sent to the
early deaths as each and every one for
them failed the final selection and as a
result of this perceived failure as well
as Haruka Ducky's grief the souls of the
children remained in this world until
they were able to be put to rest by
tonzura and it's not as if the children
held any animosity towards arucard Aki
either with Malcolm or going so far as
to state that she loves him and that is
a familial bond at its finest and a
great example of how such a simple idea
can underpin an entire arc because
without this focus on family none of
this works the emotions would not be
strong enough to satisfactorily justify
spirit children and the euphoria of
defeating the demon that claimed them
would be just another in a long list of
generic shown and victories moving to
another more obvious example now and I
don't think we can really discuss the
brilliance of family without bringing
Zen e2 into the mix this seemingly
hopeless boy was relentlessly trained by
his grandfather and former ha Shura
jiguro khawaja MA
but despite the impossible task ahead of
him jiguro never gave up on Zen e2 and
he was thrilled when he was able to
master but one technique in regards to
Thunder breathing and this left a great
imprint on Xena too as a character who
desires more than anything to live up to
the effort that his grandfather put into
training him as well as the sheer amount
of belief that he had in him which is a
phenomena that he rarely experiences in
the world and it really does come to
define zenit too as well as his struggle
with cowardice and very much becoming
the only source of clarity going forward
family is a powerful thing after all and
in the case of the mighty you know sky
you could say that his character exists
as contrast to not only show the absence
of family but of the effect that
developing the most basic of connections
can have I mean yes I guess you know
escape was primarily raised by Bors so
he does have a UH a unique family will
say but in escape very much enters demon
slayer has a bit of a blank slate and as
a result of the bonds that he develops
with Tonto and everyone else he comes to
grow an awful lot as an individual and
it's all very obviously a result of
these close relationships that he's
developing and as a result he really
does serve as a perfect contrast
characters like Tonto and Xena too who
are well accustomed to the benefits and
detriments of family then there's also
Canal who has seen both the best and the
worst that family has to offer growing
up she lived in an incredibly abusive
environment to the point where she was
psychologically broken and even sold off
into slavery
however Canal was acquired by the cacio
sisters and that newfound sense of
family immediately and radically changed
her life and there are of course much
more subtle portrayals of family as well
such as the entirety of the hashira they
are all very purposely designed to evoke
a feeling of older siblings who have the
experience necessary to guide our
younger protagonists in this world and
you know what at first I was kind of put
off by the idea that all of the hashira
were essentially young adults because in
my mind you'd figure that the pinnacle
of power in this world might have a bit
more age and experience behind it
however instead they're all under 30 and
in fact most of them are barely into
their 20s but it is a very intentional
decision to portray them like this
because you know they have this really
cool vibe about them that younger
children have a tendency to feel towards
their older siblings because parents are
great and all but when you're a kid
there is nobody cooler in this world
than your older brother or sister so it
makes a lot of sense that the people
we're supposed to feel other course in
the world take on that familial role and
without going into spoilers most of them
to embody this idea to a fault when they
are eventually export in the series so
they do act as yet another wonderful
result of what happens when you put the
core concept of family into action and
of course all of this is just a tiny
portion of how family has influenced
every facet of demon slayer and going
forward that core concept is only going
to become more obvious and I believe
that that is why the series has struck
such a chord with people because firstly
family as stated before is an idea that
is almost never given heavy focus in
assurance series at least not as an
underlying concept
so as a result to Chernin fans demon
slayer feels really fresh and the
advantages of doing this idea properly
bring to the table impacts the readers
and watches in ways that they aren't
necessarily used to in one piece my hero
academia hunter hunter whatever it is
and just to be clear once again though
every other story I've mentioned does
effectively use family but it's done so
as more of a narrative accessory they
invoke family when it's necessary to
invoke family you know like during a
flashback or an urgent situation here
and there to give a character some
really solid motivation but none of them
use it as their prime factor and that's
not to say they should either every
successful series has its own reasons
and ideas that have led it to widespread
popularity and family just happens to be
demon Slayers bread and butter a series
could choose to focus on any number of
different concepts but the most
important thing is that they explore
them in depth and in a dramatically
impactful manner and demon slayer is
nothing short of a masterpiece in that
regard I think there are definitely
things to fault about Demon Slayer
especially after reading the manga but a
lot of it is nitpicky stuff and none of
it outweighs how marvelous a job the
series has done of what it set out to do
and you know what that core exploration
combined for the brilliant anime
adaptation well in that case I think
it's pretty inevitable that the only
option left for Demon Slayer was to go
on and take the world by storm and that
pretty much does it for the secret to
the success of Demon Slayer if you
enjoyed this video and the content this
channel produce in general then please
do consider donating to the new
worldview patreon because the support of
all of your amazing people is what
continues to make this channel possible
and if patreon isn't quite your style
then please do leave this video a like
share or subscribe because it also helps
support this channel an incredible
amount and if you'd like to join the fun
at any time then please do head over to
my discord server where a wide array of
shenanigan tree takes place on a daily
basis and finally please do comment with
your thoughts on family and Demon Slayer
this has been the new world of you and
I'll see you next time
you